you know there are a few things in this
world that drive me more insane than me
posting a video about bad translations
or physical release or whatever and
someone invariably saying well I like
the mistake so it's okay no shut up stop
being stupid it's not okay for some
reason with Japanese media there's this
weird thing where half the people in the
world see mistakes in Translation and
just shrug it off like it's no big deal
but can you imagine the flip side like
imagine Avengers endgame releases in
Japan and in the emotional scene where
Thor talks with his mother one last time
and retrieves milir instead of him
saying I'm still worthy the Japanese
line says something like I don't know
hey no I've got two weapons like okay no
no one is going to perish in real life
because of that mess of translation but
it's a product that people are paying
for you're paying to see the product not
some random dude's interpretation of it
it's okay to care about stuff let me
care about this